just into us moments ago the House GOP
is releasing the text of their new
immigration proposal expected to be
brought to the floor as early as next
week Wow what's the rush among the
highlights ending the controversial
policy known as catch and release
ensuring minors who went to the country
illegally are not separated from their
parents that's not gonna draw more
people in calls for an end to the Visa
Lottery system but instead just
reallocates the 55,000 visas to
supposedly a merit-based program let's
discuss with congressman Ron De Santis
and money for the wall apparently 25
billion for the wall Ron no e-verify
which I'm told doesn't matter but I
think it matters or doesn't like you do
verify means you don't work you don't
get to work unless you are verified to
be legally in the country correct yeah
and so chamber doesn't want if you're
doing an amnesty that's one point eight
maybe more million people yeah that's
what that is we don't have that in the
bullets but there's a huge Haman guess
what's gonna happen that's gonna create
an incentive for more people to come
illegally and if you don't have the
verify to kind of remove a disincentive
that wall even if that's a good-faith
effort at the wall and I'm not sure it
is that ain't gonna be built in a day
you need to drill strip the courts of
jurisdiction over lawsuits it because
this thing will get tied up forever with
the wall so without Eve Arif I you're
gonna have a border surge like we had in
2014 that obviously is gonna have a lot
of people moving but that's also wet
kiss to the drug cartels because they're
gonna be able to move a lot of product
across the border if there's a border
I'm told
asylum fraud is addressed but again it
just was released 293 pages we haven't
had time to go through here's the thing
tomorrow night
good lad bill has what we campaigned on
the good lab bill and migration here's
what they say they won't get it through
they won't get it through it's not gonna
pass the Senate probably won't pass the
house although Paul Ryan will apparently
it will be brought up next week good lad
then I hear good let's was involved in
writing this new bill I don't know if he
was or not we need to defund sanctuary
cities we need e-verify need end chain
migration get rid of the diversity Visa
Lottery we need to do all those things
and look peek make people go on record
for that it's not a popular vote in the
Republican Party but even in these
Democrat districts people want Iver
by I mean it's not even a partisan thing
at what the grassroots level isn't want
a verify so the money that's coming into
these campaigns they do not want to
check the identity of people and that
means undermines the rule of law harms
taxpayers and lowers wages for Americans
that's not a good okay so but they'll
say it's the best we can do and it does
address some of the chain migration
again we'll see how much it addresses we
understand that the amnesty could reach
parents as well so it's not just the
developers good lord parents are
included it's gonna go to the Senate
either died or they're gonna make it
worse those are the only two options
Senate ain't gonna just pass this and so
you're really running a risk that this
could get really devil's advocate here
they say that you know freedom caucus
people yet you never can govern you you
say you want to get something done but
then when you can get something done
limit chain migration bring down the the
immigration of the country you just say
no we're not gonna do it the goal is to
end illegal immigration
this would fuel more illegal immigration
if you don't have things like e-verify
that's just a bit will it work yes or no
the president's got to think long and
hard about this because something this
seems like a bum's rush to me i I don't
like the feeling of being rushed no
committee hearings oh that's convenient